c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
sont les bienvenus sur france inter à la
une ce soir de 30 ans de prison requis
contre blaise compaoré dans les presser
de l'assassinât de thomas sankara
selon le parquet militaire l'ancien
président du burkina faso était le
donneur d'ordre le compte rendu
d'audience avec notre correspondant
canine aussi dans un instant les lions
de la teranga décoré de la plus haute
distinction du pays l'ordre national du
lion leur a été remis lors d'une
cérémonie présidée par le chef de l'état
macky sall leur victoire en coupe
d'afrique des nations les élever au rang
de héros nous irons à dakar dans cette
édition
[Musique]
il s'appelle giddey ce chat la band'à il
a 92 ans cet homme originaire du malawi
est devenu une véritable star sur tik
tok grâce à un morceau devenue virale on
vous racontera son histoire à la fin de
ce journal
c'est lui qui avait intérêt à ce que le
cours réussissent lui c'est blaise
compaoré l'ancien président burkinabè
absent au procès et la phrase a été
prononcée par le parquet militaire lors
des réquisitoire dans le procès de
l'assassinât de thomas sankara le
parquet militaire qui a requis 30 ans de
prison contre blaise compaore compte
rendu d'audience avec notre
correspondant à ouagadougou fiel de 6
30 ans de prison ferme contre blaise
compaoré hyacinthe kafando 20 ans de
prison ferme contre gilbert diendiéré ce
sont les peines requises par le parquet
militaire de ouagadougou dont le procès
des assassins présumés de l'ex président
burkinabè thomas sankara tuer avec 12 de
ses compagnons le réquisitoire avait
commencé par un rappel chronologique des
événements de ce fameux 15 octobre 1987
date du coup d'état rappelons que depuis
le premier jour du procès le 11 octobre
dernier seuls 12 des 14 accusés sont
présents dont le général gilbert
diendiéré 61 ans un des principaux chefs
de l'armée lors du putsch de 1987 et est
incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt et de
correction des armées la maca depuis six
ans car déjà condamnés à 20 ans de
prison pour son putsch manqué de 2015 le
principal accusé l'ancien président
blaise compaoré arrivé au pouvoir par ce
putsch ne s'est jamais présenté au
procès ses avocats avaient dénoncé un
simulacre de procès devant un tribunal
d'exception soupçonné d'avoir été le
commanditaire de l'assassinât de sankara
ce qu'il a toujours nié il a été chassé
du pouvoir en 2014 par la rue et vit
depuis en exil en côte d'ivoire ces
chefs d'inculpation sur la complicité
d'assassinât le recel de cadavre et
l'attentât à la sûreté de l'état pts
autre grand absent la juge en chef et
hyacinthe kafando ancien commandant de
la garde de comparer ensuite depuis 2016
et qui est soupçonné d'avoir mené de
commando ayant assassiné thomas sankara
et ses compagnons
l'audience a été suspendue pour
permettre aux avocats de la défense de
préparer leurs plaidoiries reprise
prévue le mi mars prochain
les festivités se poursuivent au sénégal
après la victoire des lions de la
teranga en coupe d'afrique des nations
ce mardi les joueurs et membres de
l'encadrement était décoré par le
président pas par le président de la
plus haute distinction de la nation ils
ont aussi reçu l'équivalent de 75 mille
euros et deux terrains chacun 1 à dakar
et un autre à diamniadio la nouvelle
ville à une trentaine de kilomètres de
dakar nos correspondants elimane dao et
sarah sakho ont assisté à la cérémonie
écoutez
c'est sous les hourras du public chaque
joueur a été décoré par le président
sénégalais macky sall ils ont reçu
l'ordre national du lion qui est la plus
haute distinction
sénégalaise la cérémonie qui a duré
après deux heures s'est tenue devant le
palais présidentiel sur l'avenue léopold
sédar senghor pour permettre justement
au public de participer le sénégal a
donc une fois de plus honorer ces
champions qui lui ont ramené la coupe
d'afrique des nations pour la première
fois depuis 60 ans bravo chariot
ce trophée
nous ne tenons aussi grâce à coach
allait aussi c'est
merci
elle tactico
d'avoir mené à bon port le trou
pour nous ramener le premier trophée
continental de football de notre
histoire les lions vont désormais
pouvoir retourner dans leurs clubs
respectifs avec un objectif en tête en
ce qui concerne la sélection nationale
la qualification pour la prochaine coupe
du monde qui se tiendra en décembre
prochain
la coupe d'afrique des nations à sept
évidemment du sport et de la joie
surtout lors des victoires mais les
compétitions aussi leur lot de
polémiques c'est le cas au gabon est la
question qui fâche concerne l'entretien
des stades et des infrastructures
construit spécialement pour ce genre
d'événement certain stade conçu pour
accueillir des rencontres de la can 2012
et 2017 sont aujourd'hui dans un état
déplorable ces investissements avaient
coûté au trésor public gabonais plus
d'un milliard d'euros reportage de nos
correspondants libreville tony menga
ismaël obiang élus carmel nouveau
des équipements abîmé des bus ayant
servi lors de la can 2010 est abandonné
dans la broussaille
depuis quatre ans le stade de l'amitié
sino-gabonaise de libreville se dégrade
c'était tout bon endroit
dans l'enceinte ce jour là vers l'aigle
ecobat n'en croit pas ses yeux le
journaliste sportif n'avait pas remis
les pieds dans ce stade de 40000 places
depuis la coupe d'afrique des nations de
2010 est un stade sortie du tr voilà dix
ans censé être une infrastructure
sportive majeure pour les gabonais il
servait il ya quelques mois encore des
centres de tesco vide c'est un peu la
tristesse parce que
c'était ça c'était un endroit qui
inspirait une certaine fierté il y avait
là les journalistes du monde entier et
quand il était là le gabon était
valorisé aujourd'hui quand je reviens
quand je vois ça c'est fait triste des
stades délaissées comme l'une des plus
grandes et des plus anciennes enceinte
du pays située quelques kilomètres plus
loin
les travaux de rénovation du stade omar
bongo n'ont jamais vu le jour pourtant
l'état gabonais y avait investi près de
100 milliards de francs cfa soit 154
millions d'euros des installations
vétustes et une pelouse est rodé que ces
jeunes du quartier sont désormais les
seuls à utiliser depuis deux ans le
championnat national est à l'arrêt comme
l'entretien du stade un tram pour ulrich
kessany ancien capitaine de l'équipe
gabonaise selon lui l'organisation d'une
compétition comme la can aurait dû
booster le football gabonais lorsqu'on a
quelque chose d'historique comme ça on
doit pouvoir se battre pour le réalité
parce que c'est une histoire
de plusieurs générations c'est
l'histoire du gabon c'est l'histoire du
football camerounais quelle est la
logique aujourd'hui de construire des
infrastructures pour qu'ils ne servent
pas à notre compétition domestique c'est
une problématique je pense que le
ministre des sports devrait en répondre
entre 2012 et 2017 le gabon a dépensé
plus de 700 milliards de francs cfa soit
1 milliard 66 millions d'euros pour
l'organisation des deux coupes d'afrique
des dépenses qui ont pesé lourd sur le
contribuable et qui sont toujours décrié
par les opposants au régime en place
sollicité le ministre gabonais des
sports n'a pas donné suite à nos
demandes
et ce soir on fait le point sur la
vaccination contre le paludisme le
vaccin continue de faire ses preuves au
kenya par exemple plus de cent mille
enfants ont été vaccinés depuis le
lancement d'un programme pilote en 2019
le nombre d'infections et de cas graves
ne cesse de chuter le renverse techer
lucie iachini se rendait à l'hôpital
trois fois par mois pour soigner les
crises de paludisme de ses enfants et
lorsqu'on lui a proposé de les faire
vacciner contre la maladie la jeune
kényane n'a pas hésité depuis tous les
tests sont revenus négatifs de quoi
convaincre sa soeur de lui emboîter le
pas
obama tenait depuis que les enfants de
celui-ci ont été vaccinées ils n'ont
plus le paludisme donc j'ai décidé
d'amener mon fils pour qu'il soit
protégé lui aussi
lancé en 2019 au kenya le programme
pilote du vaccin contre le paludisme
commence à porter ses fruits le
personnel soignant dit avoir constaté
une baisse des infections et des cas
graves depuis le début de la campagne
nous avons observé une réduction des cas
de paludisme
même chez les enfants qui contractent la
maladie les caisses en moins grave hier
grand spécialiste de la recherche sur le
paludisme
le docteur simon carew qui assure que le
vaccin ne présente pas de danger pour la
santé et qu'il pourrait permettre de
réduire les cas d'environ 40% dans les
zones à risque un outil révolutionnaire
pour lutter contre la maladie mais aussi
contre la pauvreté
les familles n'auront plus besoin de
dépenser de l'argent pour aller à
l'hôpital pour acheter des médicaments
ou même pour enterrer leur enfant
nouveau tube le paludisme reste l'une
des maladies les plus meurtrières au
monde et eu plus de six cent mille
personnes chaque année la majorité en
afrique subsaharienne
celui février 2022 marque le 10ème mois
de captivité du journaliste olivier
dubois otages au mali au nom de la
liberté de la presse en soutien à sa
famille à ses proches nous aurons chaque
mois une pensée pour lui jusqu'à sa
libération
je vous propose de faire le point sur la
situation avec notre correspondante au
mali anne fleur lespiau nous n'avons pas
d'élément nouveau concernant sa
détention rien depuis cette vidéo de 21
secondes publiée sur les réseaux sociaux
un mois après son enlèvement à gao le 8
avril 2021 une vidéo qui fait office
aujourd'hui d'unique preuve de vie
olivier explique être retenu par des
membres de la branche sahélienne d'al
qaïda le groupe de soutien à l'islam et
aux musulmans un groupe qui on le sait
est responsable de la majorité des
enlèvements au mali dans cette ville aux
olivier dubois appelle les autorités
françaises à se mobiliser pour sa
libération alors concernant cette
mobilisation il est difficile d'avoir
des détails sur ce sujet cibles dont le
travail se fait on le sait dans la
discrétion difficile également de savoir
si la france et le mali collaborent sur
le dossier d'olivier dubois côté
français le gouvernement a récemment
rappelé que la france n'oubliez pas le
journaliste français côté malien au mois
d'octobre le premier ministre magnan
choguel maïga bien répondait dans une
interview accordée au journal le monde
le monde que des discussions étaient en
cours et que le gouvernement malien
était très en les ch'ti
le chef du gouvernement avait alors
rappelé que les libérations successives
que d'élus mais libération successives
en octobre et en novembre
2021 avait eu lieu à savoir trois otages
chinois une otage colombienne soeur
gloria ou encore le rappeur malien
docteur kiev délibération qui sont un
signe encourageant notamment pour ses
proches ici à bamako vous l'avez dit
cela fait maintenant plus de trois cents
jours soit bientôt un an qu'olivier
retenu en tant qu'otage s'accompagne ici
à bamako a demandé à la france qu'il n'y
ait pas d'opération militaire pour le
libérer de leur côté les autorités
maliennes ont assuré que le cas
d'olivier ne serait ni impacté par le
contexte actuel ni par la crise multiple
que traverse le mali mais une fois de
plus difficile de confirmer ou même d'en
savoir plus
allez avant de se quitter je vous emmène
au malawi à la rencontre de jds xala
mandat cet homme de 92 ans est devenu
une star sur la plateforme en ligne tik
tok avec un titre vu plus de 80 millions
de fois de l'afrique du sud aux
philippines son titre acoustique est
entraînant ligny vous a été
réinterprétée et remixé des dizaines de
fois le renverse et cher
jds xala mandat n'est pas sur les
réseaux sociaux et ne possède même pas
de téléphone portable mais sur tik tok
ce malawite de 92 ans est une véritable
star sa chanson ligne ou a été visionnée
plus de 80 millions de fois sur la
plateforme une notoriété est tardive
dans ce musicien aux 70 ans de carrière
apprécié chaque instant
quand je chante ça divertit les jambes
ils sont heureux ils dansent et ça me
rend fier
en automne 2020 jadech alamanda
enregistre une version reggae de sa
chanson ligne ou écrites 20 ans plus tôt
en hommage à sa fille le succès est
immédiat sur youtube mais surtout sur
tik tok où la reprise devient virale et
fait le tour du monde depuis j death ne
peut plus sortir sans être reconnu par
des hordes de jeunes fans inspiré par
l'énergie et la sagesse du nonagénaire
j'aime sa musique parce que c'est un
ancien il sait beaucoup de choses sur la
vie il partage ses expériences
et il fait passer des messages sensible
dans ses chansons et lavaur 16 forêt et
naissance
depuis quelques mois les demandes de
concerts s'enchaînent pour gide s est
l'artiste a même été invité à dîner par
le président du malawi mais à ce jour j
des chats lamanda ne touche aucun droit
d'auteur pour ses vidéos aux millions de
vues sur les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
journal de l'afrique c'est avec nous
dans quelques instants la suite de paris
direct avec audrey racines
[Musique]